[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce iront
parler sport votre émission préférée sur
le sport local dans ce nouvel épisode il
y aura comme d'hab et d'habitudes des
analyses des débats et des duels
acharnés entre nos experts sur
l'actualité sportive du département
pendant près d'une heure aujourd'hui
quatre super stars du sport local nous
font l'honneur de venir sur cette
émission présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite par l'un des pères
fondateurs de cette émission est notre
spécialiste cyclisme c'est un véritable
compétiteur dans l'âme l'ars a fait
récemment la deuxième place aux
championnats du monde masters comme sur
la piste ne lâche rien sur ce talk pour
nous apporter des analyses pointues et
détaillé l'excellent le capitaine yann
dujarrier est avec nous le pistard de
vélizy 78 bon sens michael bonsoir voila
une nouvelle émission pour vous prêts
voilà vous êtes frais est ce que vous
êtes chauffé malgré le froid qui invite
le bruit ou enfin heureusement il ya le
chauffage dans la voiture pour me dire
voilà ce que ça qui fait il fait bien
froid en ce moment voilà et donc tant
mieux on va voir un vrai hiver et vous
êtes préparé également au niveau de vos
analyses oui pour cette émission comme
d'habitude vous êtes chauffé on passe de
l'autre côté à musique elle est aussi
douce que la neige mais elle ne vous
laissera pas de glace avec ses analyses
et son sens de la répartie sur les
barres de pole dance de son club de
versailles à n'hésite pas à réchauffer
l'atmosphère avec des figures
incroyables toutes les semaines notre
ambassadrice de charme hélène de la
grange est avec nous bonjour allen voilà
la présentation de reflète bien oui
j'aime bien plus douces comme la neige
et en plus c'est circonstances
aujourd'hui n'ont qu'un seul prisme a
sorti les purs
repasse à ma droite musique c'est
peut-être l'un des hommes les plus
brillants des zibeline il connaît tout
sur le sport local ou presque c'est une
honte clope et 10 humaines pour
l'attirer dans cette émission
aujourd'hui nous avons dû lui promettre
un livre sur le sport local pour noël le
professeur frédéric anderson du club du
football américain des templiers des
encours est avec nous et nous fait
l'honneur de venir sur cette émission
nouvelle fois toujours un grand plaisir
voilà c'est voilà le le petit livre de
noël sur le sport local c'est un plaisir
centre permettra c'est votre cadeau un
peu tendance en valeur pour étudier les
livres c'est toujours pratique alors on
termine surtout le table à ma gauche il
est le champion de la répartie le
sébastien chabal des punchline on
l'avait perdu de vue depuis plusieurs
émissions mais il a affronté le froid et
le verglas pour venir aujourd'hui mon
ces dames en ski ne pourra pas dedans
dans cette émission il vous a manqué il
nous a manqué et l'ex-entraîneur de
plaisir la légende j'en us est avec une
conception mission bonjour bonsoir
michael voilà vous avez un petit peu
perdu de vue sur les derniers rangs des
missions deux émissions de démission au
bon ou au fan mle précisant le risque
justement deux émissions 2 bon j'ai pas
de sécu non voilà une selon le choc de
leur forme j'espère que je peux être
trop dissipé par mes camarades voilà
sinon surtout pas vos camarades un papa
marc bru
on va passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission jolie nous allons parler de
boxe avec la très belle victoire de
l'élan courtois adila hamouma dit au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines une victoire qui lui permet
d'espérer un titre mondial dans les
prochains mois nous reviendrons
également sur la transat jacques vabre 2
heavy nous a terminé dans le top 10 mais
avant de développer ces thèmes nous
allons parler de handball et de la très
belle performance du club de plaisir
on commence donc par du handball et le
championnat de nationale 3 le promu
plaisir n'en finit plus de gagner dans
cette division les plaisirs oies se sont
imposé 29 à 27 à domicile contre
marolles une équipe pourtant favorite
pour la montée en fin de saison pour
battre son adversaire du jour
l'entraîneur plaisir roi victor à
garrigues avait mis en place une
stratégie on les écoute je pense qu'on a
très bien exploité un moment donné où
ils ont décidé de jouer un joueur de
plus où
on a on a pris le choix tactiques de ne
pas s'aplatir aider c'est quelqu'un de
la circulation ce qui les a gênés et du
coup comme il joue sans gardien on a
récupéré des ballons qui nous ont permis
de mettre des buts dans un but vide tout
simplement même si on aurait pu être
encore plus efficient sur cette partie
là bon on met deux buts dans un but vide
il ya plus de à la fin
mais c'est dit avec cette victoire
plaisir occupe désormais la deuxième
place du championnat avec un bilan de 5
victoires et 2 défaites en sept matches
avec une dynamique de quatre victoires
consécutives mais le capitaine de
l'équipe benjamins modeste ne s'enflamme
pas on écoute on savait que sous la
salle est très très costaud on sait très
bien préparé toute la semaine et on est
content ça paye ça veut peut-être dire
qu'audi aussi on était costaud voilà je
pense que maintenant on va être attendu
un peu partout et dès que voilà rien
n'est joué cette saison on perd deux
matches on est huitième on en gagne deux
on est premiers donc voilà chaque mois
je vais très très importants et décisifs
on voit bien que dans sa réponse
benjamin modestes restent modestes
effectivement l'équipe reste humble
c'est une force alliée du jarrier
justement que l'équipe garde un peu les
pieds sur terre malgré cette très bonne
dynamique je disais de quatre victoires
consécutives le championnat ne fait ni
guinée n'est qu'à son début
voilà septième match oui c'était un
match fou qui sont ils ont pas fait
encore on n'attendait pas c'est pas
encore passé la première lan n'a pas
encore passé les matches tous les
matches aller donc ils ont raison d'être
d'être prudent moi je pense que
la sueur sur ce type de résultat il
pense qu'aujourd'hui ils ont déjà acquis
l'objectif de début de saison qui devait
de rester en nationale 3 donc c'est une
déjà une belle satisfaction et puis ben
voilà deux continuent de prendre les
matches un par un sens sans avoir sans
avoir peur mon effet maintenant ils vont
commencer à être attendus par par les
autres équipes mais
bon voilà ça va pas moi je pense pas que
ça changera leur dynamique et puis
l'heure leur envie de continuer de
continuer sur ce rythme la question sur
ce thème peuvent-ils tenir le rythme
toute cette saison et yann vous me
faites des transitions magnifique est ce
qu'ils peuvent tenir le rythme toute
cette saison c'était un roi oui oui vous
êtes tous unanimes genre pourquoi
répondu oui et pourquoi pas
mais parce que tout simplement ce qui
est engagé maintenant ces agrégés après
ils sont pas sauvés parce qu'elle devra
alors l e le classement quand même c'est
très serré entre le jeu contre
l'avant-dernier et le deuxième c'est à
dire plaisir est à cinq points je crois
voilà ravageur exemple qui a été battu
par plaisir était 2e juste avant la
honte voilà donc oui on est tous les
jours le poche quand même on est donc là
projet ça on peut pas non plus tirer des
plans sur la comète en dix ans ils ne
sont pas loin d'effrayer légalement on
le voit 19 17 voilà tout à fait tout à
fait non mais tout dans un mouchoir de
poche donc pour l'instant de tirer des
conclusions hâtives il faut éviter
maintenant la dynamique est là il faut
s'en servir collectivement on essaie
beaucoup mieux naître de la dynamique de
victoires que le contraire donc
forcément même s'ils sont attendus
puisque c'est sûr qu'ils vont être
attendus partout mais en tout cas ce qui
est pris n'est plus à prendre est ce qui
prive en hiver ne craint pas le gel donc
c'est le retour de jean 1500 voilà ils
voulaient bug
habituel les cinq premières saisons
l'émission
ellen vous de votre côté vous avez
répondu oui également pourquoi d'une
façon de bien ou de toute façon ils sont
déjà bien lancés dans dans ce rythme là
il n'y a pas de raison que ça change qui
continuent ils ont l'envié et ils ont
montré qu'ils étaient capables après ils
sont montés de
voilà la division voilà donc ça va
forcément être peut-être un peu plus
compliqué mais voilà six laisse pas
abattre qui se laisse pas impressionner
je pense que sur ce point de vue je suis
toujours
moi je suis toujours ravi quand on
change de klaxon de classement qu'on
monte donc oui je tends fins et s'il ya
un petit côté toujours impressionnant
donc après s'affaire donc faut
travailler encore mais ça doit faire y'a
pas de raison que ça autrement fabrique
ils ont déjà prouvé qu'ils avaient leur
place dans cette division ah bah on ne
gagne pas cinq matches par hasard non
plus c'est aussi l'effort enfin le fruit
de tous leurs efforts consentis jusqu'à
maintenant et puis montre bien que c'est
saison gagné ses cinq matches face à
dire que déjà sur les matches retour ils
ont encore la chance d'en gagner cinq de
plus parce qu'ils sont capables ils ont
montré ils ont prouvé que qu'ils étaient
capables c'est pas peut-être que et on
voit que les enchaîne aussi les
victoires et c'est vrai que ça c'est
important parce que ça demande beaucoup
de maturité et bas comme disait benjamin
de pas s'enflammer à chaque match de
rester les pieds sur terre c'est
toujours important dans une équipe de
pas s'enflammer quand tout va bien et ne
pas sombrer non plus quand tout va mal
de rester à peu près au milieu toujours
être modérée et dans la victoire et dans
la défaite c'est ça je pense qu'il
permet de durer jusqu'au bout et il
arrive également à gagner à l'extérieur
c'est un signe également que seul son
niveau et son niveau il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas l'air d'avoir des clips qui sont
incapables de battre on voit bien par
leur classement et sont déjà deuxièmes
de leur classement même si c'est que
sept matches dans la saison on voit
qu'ils sont pas là par hasard et que ce
qu'ils ont gagné l'année dernière et ben
il confirme encore cette année c'est
vraiment une bonne chose il ya nous est
d'accord ils ont prouvé déjà ouais la
seule chose que je leur souhaite pas
c'est de terminer premiers du
championnat et de monter en nationale 2
directement je pense que
s'ils veulent pouvoir assumer une montée
future faut pas qu'elle se fasse dans la
précipitation il faut que ça se fasse ça
fasse par étapes donc donc voilà well as
prison attendu quand même sept ans avant
de monter justement nationale 3
peut-être que l'équipe est déjà fait
peut-être pas eu lieu on va pas leur
temps à perdre c'était 27 ans pourquoi
monter en nationale 2 mai mais voilà
peut-être une saison ou deux en national
en nationale 3 ce bien bien ce bien se
structurer pour pouvoir monter parce
qu'ils ont quand même pas fait
énormément de recrutement sur le sur le
changement bien sûr que peut-être que la
fin la dernière saison ils ont pu monter
peut-être avec une avec une forte
domination voilà faut rester prudent
dans en arrivant à ce niveau là pour ne
pas rentrer dans une spirale qui
pourrait être l très négative et et être
préjudiciable parce que on peut très
rapidement vite vite vite retombé très
bas donc donc voilà faut faut vraiment
construire est resté sur pourquoi rester
et sans non plus aussi vouloir aller
trop
il y à un moment il faut rester faut
savoir rester à sa place aussi et
maintenant donc vous alors conseillé de
terminer mon nom mais rien gâché les
premiers pas prêts a plaisir à plaisir
cette année au rugby sont plus de mal à
beaucoup plus de ballons m'en parlent et
je crois un peu plus tard mais voilà
c'est bien il ya un plaisir qui remplace
l'autre mais voilà faut faut faire
attention c'est une sportive en tout cas
ce que je dis tout à fait l'effet de
surprise jean vous pensez qu'il va
disparaître également sur la phase
retour des matchs de national 3 ah non
il n'y a plus d'effet de surprise la
plus l'effet de surprise en volailles ce
soir venant ils se sont affirmés comme
et que comme prétendant à la montée en
nationale 2 quand on finit quand on est
deuxième du classement avec 5 victoires
sur 7 matches y a plus l'effet de
surprise d'ailleurs le capitaine a eu la
lucidité de dire qu'ils se mettraient
sur la table du partout il ya plus de
surprise là après c'est une poule qui a
l'air très serré parce que je vois les
résultats c'est quand même
c'est toujours des résultats assez de
2,3 buts beaucoup de rencontres se
jouent à un deux ou trois buts quoi donc
ça ça veut dire que les équipes sont
assez équilibrés dans cette poule donc
il faut vraiment vraiment voilà il faut
vraiment rien qui restent qui reste
lucide concentrés et surtout avec
beaucoup d'humilité continuer à
travailler et garder se plaçant du haut
du tableau après après si peu à monter
en nationale 2 je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vos camarades parce que
s'ils peuvent remonter de suite en
nationale 2 vous faut pas qu'ils
hésitent parce que comme vous avez si
bien dit ils ont attendu sept ans pour
monter de prénationale en nationale 3
donc là six avaient saisonnalité un
petit porte qui s'ouvre il souffre déjà
selon nous l'auront mérité sportivement
parce que c'est jamais facile de le
monter et je crois qu'il faut la prendre
et puis après travailler travailler avec
de nouveaux éléments mais faut pas il
faut surtout pas surtout pas laisser
passer le monde des affaires et qu'il va
falloir qu'il change de stratégie
peut-être sur les prochains matches là
ils ont joué sur l'effet de surprise
mais palette qui devront composer avec
d'autres éléments sur les prochaines
rencontres bon on verra bien après c'est
aussi la qualité de l'entraîneur sa
capacité à analyser les adversaires qui
vont se mettre en travers de leur chemin
dans les matchs en tout cas son coup de
poker a bien fonctionné oui et puis
après fin même si les équipes adverses
maintenant comment savoir leur niveau et
ont peut-être une petite citée de leurs
qualités leurs forces et leurs
faiblesses c'est aussi vrai pour pur
plaisir et pour profond pour tout le
monde quoi dire que même ses adversaires
ont des nouvelles données sur sur eux
mais eux aussi ont ils savent comment
quel niveau os peuvent quel type de jeu
développé les autres équipes et c'est
vrai que dans la durée comme lé match
aller retour je pense pas que ils se
feront surprendre plus que ça sur le
retour voir ce qui ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est de voir ce que
sont devenus tous les premiers qui les
ont maintenus à la deuxième place
pendant sept ans est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours en nationale 3 est ce qu'ils
sont montés dessus parce que ça se
trouve ils sortent d'une poule qui est
vraiment très forte et au final
leur monter leur permettrait peut-être
de soirée une montée il y a trois ans
juste pour deux buts dont qu'il avait le
niveau sauf pour des buts donc s'ils
sortent d'une poule qui est vraiment
forte avec les autres équipes qui ont
continué leur monter leur ascension ils
peuvent eux ils peuvent espérer suivre
le même chemin et vous pensez qu'il peut
y avoir une baisse physique ou pas sur
les prochaines rencontres
là ils ont ils ont démarré assez fort
est ce qu'il peut avoir une baisse
physique après la trêve par exemple
hivernale
l'îlot comme iso 15 j'espère vous un
préparateur physique qui évite ce genre
de choses et qui prévoit le trou
physique au moment où il le faut par
rapport aux objectifs du groupe et
à l'état de forme des joueurs parce que
ça c'est vrai que c'est à prendre en
compte aussi il faut pas qu'ils aient
des blessés parce que ça fait partie du
sport dans le ressort et s'ils arrivent
à conserver le groupe et la dynamique
qu'ils ont actuellement je crois que ça
peut ça peut vraiment leur sourire il
n'y a pas de souci j'y crois mais y
croyez il monte cette année ou pas sur
genlis il monte il monte trop long mais
on peut pas on ne peut pas dire ça on
est à un tiers du championnat et deux
tiers du championnat il faut être
l'austral a vu cela pour dire s'ils
montent ou pas surtout c'est très serré
ça joue à la salle c'est une c'est une
montée sur 7 sur cette poule qui se
détaillent il ya trop d'éléments
extérieurs à prendre un jaune pour
savoir et si j'y vois là jeudi par les
blessures de mathieu gagné on est
premier de matches perdus on est
huitième donc voilà folle attendra
encore un peu voilà
alors nous allons à présent passer notre
deuxième thématique elle concerne à la
boxe le 11 novembre dernier l'élan
courtois a dit lahm ou mady a conservé
sa ceinture européenne des poids super
moyens en battant aux points le français
christophe rey brasse au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
les trois juges l'ont désigné vainqueur
on écoute la réaction d'adil hamouma dit
juste après son combat
encore champion d'europe bondi dans les
yvelines grande fierté et encore merci
pour ceux qui me soutiennent une fierté
un objectif terminer on est parti pour
d'autres objectifs encore le monde on
l'a entendu dans sa réaction juste après
à ce combat il pensait déjà au titre
mondial dans la catégorie mais peut-il
réaliser cet exploit à 37 ans oui ou non
ou étaient
37 ans adil abou madi
champion d'europe vous êtes un des six
fils ont fait un petit duel entre hélène
et yan yan où commencer
seulement je suis seul en contre mais
non il ya un moment faut être faut être
réaliste le problème je porterai qui
enfin le la soul de soucis qu'il ya
c'est que en face de lui il ya haute
niveau mondial il ya un jeune anglais
qui qui qui lui est acquis qu'il a
réparé utilisé mais qui là qu'il l'a mis
ko au premier round la dernière fois
donc kaloum smith voilà qui est le
champion la catégorie 23 combats pour
vingt trois victoires en sept ans voilà
donc dont tu as dix ans
10 en deux mois il
hérite à paris voilà il est
débile des plus grands il ya une tour en
allonge je pense que voilà c'est dit
blanc peut pas dire que il a il a fallu
que d'autres français n'a pas le niveau
et il a largement le niveau pour être
champion du monde mais
mais voilà en face de lui il ya il ya
cet anglais qui est
phénoménal dans la catégorie mais
attention c'était en avril 2016 oui
d'accord mais oui a dit là était plus
jeune
[Rires]
après je sais que c'est un c'est un
boxeur qui arrive sur le tard qui arrive
sur le tard mais
je pense que je pense quand même que là
pour lui c'est peut-être un petit peu
trop tard malheureusement et c'est
quelque chose qu'il aurait qu'il aurait
certainement pu obtenir 6 il s il avait
commencé la boxe la botte plus tôt
maintenant quand on quand on vous voit
quand on quand on l'entend sus à la fin
à la fin d'un match qui qui c'est qui
s'est terminée qualité qui a été jusqu'à
là jusqu'à là jusqu'au 12e round bien
voilà je me demande où il a l'air quand
même relativement frais il est bas il
n'est pas abîmée il ne pense qu'à ça
donc c'est quelque chose qu'ils animent
ce combat était considéré par les
spécialistes de box en france comme l'un
des plus beaux coups de l'année donc un
beau combat moi je vois là on voit les
frais il est enfin comme je disais à sa
salle à nîmes c'est quelque chose qu'il
a envie même faut qu'ils des seuils mais
maintenant voilà
juste beaucoup de courage parce que
parce que remonter sur le ring après
avoir eu un ko au premier round
faux faux
soyez dans la tirer les conséquences et
les leçons et il a appris énormément de
7 des deux sets de 7 défaites et où est
donc il s'enquit qui peut le faire mais
voilà bon courage et depuis les trois
victoires en trois combats depuis
calmées smith ouais mais bon c'est pas
au niveau mondial
hélène justement jean vous c'est
possible après oui il a il a
l'expérience la motivation et on voit sa
réaction comme autant parler est ce qui
va forcément se retrouver face à kalin
smith je leur ai
donc là c'est
pouvoir
mais là il ya d'autres matches elle a
l'air d'y croire et on peut pas lui
enlever ce à quoi s'est
c'est son dada objective oui mais bien
sûr mais oui on va tous être champion du
monde
premier argument champion du monde à
plusieurs reprises eric anderson widor
fédé qu'anderson non pas six mois après
être champion du monde c'est toujours
quelque chose de compliqué après je
pense que
les champions d'europe donc il est et il
a conservé sa ceinture elle à vélo c'est
un champion continental ileka je pense
que il a hélas la légitimité au moins
pour prétendre à la couronne mondiale et
les champions d'europe alors que l'on ne
l est pas même si les champions du monde
votre des pages emploi n'aura donc on
peut on peut présenter aussi la faire
sous cet angle d'après on va essayer des
boxeurs qui durent enfin qui pratique
une belle boxe juste là jusqu'à tard
quand on voit pacquiao mayweather j'ai
certes ils ont la quarantaine ils ont
ils sont restés longtemps au top juste
jusque tard ils sont de la même
génération ils ont des âges similaire
laquelle dix ans d'écart entre moi je le
vois quand jeu concours avec des jeunes
qui ont moins de 30 ans c'est un peu
compliqué quand même
j'ai noté des petits chats n'ont pas
réussi à leur piquer leur place donc
ces deux vieux mais les nouveaux sont
propres la lite on sur un jeune ils ont
sur un jeune qui qui est très bon donc
il ay ay ay aller il ya les deux cahiers
différence d'âge qui est là et en plus
ce jeune anglais est très doué donc ça
fait ça fait beaucoup je pense pour je
trouve que ça fait chier je pense que
vous avez beaucoup maintenant on attend
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut que lui
souhaiter bien sûr ça se prévoit enfin
ça si
elle sera passerait quant logiquement va
mois de juin 2010 à un peu de
préparation mais c'est sûr qu'il va
falloir sur prépa régime niveau après
ses finales et le combat soit le soir
organisé et c'est encore assuré son
ancien
genlis 23 victoires quatre défaites et
un seul nul pour adil hamouma 10 3
victoires consécutives en environ il est
peut-être sur une pente ascendante
peut-être un niveau qui n'a jamais
atteint auparavant moi j'ai répondu
j'irai bonne unis oui ninon
procès dont le réseau c'est que
effectivement et c'est sa dernière
chance ça c'est sûr à 37 ans sa dernière
chance pour atteindre l'objectif est le
titre suprême mais
je pense que vous avez vu comme moi le
premier combat
même avec beaucoup de préparation je
pense quand même que ça va être mais
malheureusement ça va être quand même
mission impossible tel tellement
tellement l'anglais était quand même au
dessus je crois qu'il n'a pas dû mettre
quelques coups de poing
notre français il a été après le contre
il y aurait pu avoir également un conte
d'adil hamouma 10 sur le premier rand
ouais mais fait il aurait finalement
c'est un seul coup qui a décidé de la
suite du combat wen à celle là contre
contre l'anglais le premier combat
contre l'anglais fait cesser je trouve
qu'il ya une domination beaucoup trop
importante de l'anglais à la vue de ce
combat alors bien sûr que ça dure et ça
va lui servir de leçon et c'est à
l'extérieur également se connaissent qui
la drôme et là celle-là
je crois pas je crois pas que ce soit le
fait d'être à la maison ou à l'extérieur
qui va changer je crois que là on a
quand même on a quand même un boxeur qui
est un cran au dessus pour moi un cran
au dessus et qui sera après voilà la
boxe c'est un petit peu aussi le propos
de ce sport c'est que tout peut arriver
quoi et puis pour avoir une ouverture et
le m
et le mettre ko mais ce sera très
compliqué pour moi il pourrait y avoir
une certaine appréhension de adil
hamouma dit parce qu'il devra affronter
cet anglais calme ou smith lui qu'il a
été battu au premier rang des ce qui
peut avoir une appréhension par rapport
à ce combat
il n'y a pas d'appréhension la manière
dont il en parle juste à la sortie de
son nom de 2,2 son match il après sur
wii wheel il est surmotivé il a qu'une
envie c'est ça et c'est vraiment ce qui
ce qui me fait penser qu'il va il valait
il va essayer d'aller faire organiser ce
match pour aller le chercher mais mais
c'est vrai que
quand on voit le canton voilà moi pour
moi ce que ce que dit ce que dit jean
c'est ça c'est pour la marche et les
ailes et elle est trop trop tu si c'est
un match qui s'était joué même à ko au
bout de cinq six sept rhône peut-être
que il y aurait une possibilité là ça a
été super rapide quoi donc c'est
non je n'y a pas été cueillis à froid
c'est ça qui est pour moi il n'y a pas
été cueillis à froid ce n'est pas un
coup aux attaques il a été cueilli mais
là je veux dire l'anglais a vraiment est
allé étalé sa classe sa puissance sa
vitesse
est là dessus il a pas su répondre alors
après après c'est certain mais je crois
pas qu'il ait vraiment les moyens
les moyennes de boxe pour vraiment aller
aller rivaliser avec cet anglais est en
jeu nous faire un championnat du monde
en vélo entre les deux face à face entre
entre
fallait bien s'arrêter parce que c'est
mme boxer le croiser à
l'animal fois la fraîcheur qui dégage à
la fin d'un combat qui était jusqu'au
12e rhône c'est impressionnant justement
l'hygiène de vie enfin adil hamouma dit
préconise beaucoup enfin parle beaucoup
de son hygiène de vie à 37 ans son
hygiène de vie ça peut faire la
différence sur sur ce combat aura
toujours des carnets sur le sport de
haut niveau tous les détails
tous les airs et contre un contrôleur
sur un 100 m c'est jamais qu'une
différence de moins d'un dixième de
seconde ça joue sur pas grand chose donc
le moindre détail peut et magnifié
aucun tube il suffit juste d'être un
chouïa au dessus donc il suffit de faire
la différence si la nourriture est
l'hygiène de vie ça peut faire la
différence ça peut peut-être la clé
après je suis bas comme on a comme le
disais c'est pas forcément l'hygiène de
vie qui a fait la différence sur le sur
le match à l'image de la ram est
légalement s'il faut prendre en compte
ces cas dits la moue mahdi travail comme
animateur dans un centre de loisirs à
elancourt ce qui n'est sûrement pas le
cas de kelly smith
c'est aussi un paramètre à prendre en
compte six quand on le voit il a pas
l'air non plus de manger de la brioche 1
il a l'air d'envoyer d'envoyer du jeu et
du beau poulain il fait pas semblant
donc le garçon quand même donc
qu'on puisse compter sur un problème un
moment d'inattention ou un relâchement
de concentration au jour j à mon avis
on
verra ça dans les prochains mois on
passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur et on reste au vélotour
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines a fait le plein le 11
novembre dernier pour ce grand gala de
boxe dont on parlait juste avant ils
étaient plus de 6000 spectateurs dans
les travées de l'enceinte sportive tous
étaient ravis de voir de la boxe au
vélodrome on les écoute c'est un bel
endroit je pense pour encadrer ce type
d'événement
déjà le fait que ça se passe au
vélodrome c'est super
d'autant plus qu'il n'ya pas de gros
événements qui se passent au vélodrome
des événements sportifs donc là c'est
vraiment une belle événements et il faut
que ça continue simplement pour faire
vivre ce vélodrome quelques jours après
ce grand gala un autre événement
d'envergure était programmé au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les championnats de france de première
division la structure et nouvelle fois
attiré plusieurs milliers de spectateurs
on écoute une judoka à la sortie de la
compétition déjà que les tapis soit en
ligne c'est assez rare que sont
incomplètes comme ça les tapisseries et
c'est assez bien je pense qu'au public
ça doit être assez assez agréable aussi
on pouvoir avoir la vue surtout moi
c'est sympa c'est pas mal ça change et
du vélo au vélodrome il ya du jard y est
c'est moi je reste toujours assez
impressionné par
ben voila quand je vois des épreuves
comme comme le judo un vélodrome plein
et quand on organise une compétition
faisaient l'objet de granby gide donc
je n'ai pas de géval a donc là j'ai il
ya un problème alors je pense pas que le
problème vienne des saint quentinois je
pense que le problème vient des
fédérations qui de la fédération
française de cyclisme qui ne fait pas
son travail on apprend on apprend aussi
de la fédération française de judo qui
fait très bien son boulot d'un d'un
combat de boxe qui est organisé en trois
semaines et qui arrive quand même
à vouillé arriva année 1500 personnes
dans le vélodrome donc une réussite
alors que j'avais un gros doute aussi
sûr sûr sûr la capacité de ramener du
monde et voilà et nous on organise un
championnat d'europe il ya moi non
maintenant c'est ça et puis ben le
vélodrome est évident tous les tous les
soirs sauf le sauf le samedi soir donc
là je pense qu'il ya un gros problème et
donc c'est
et sans vouloir jeter la pierre à qui
que ce soit voilà pense vraiment que la
fédération française de cyclisme ne fait
pas son travail de communication pour
pour encourager les jeunes à venir
découvrir cette discipline qui est qui
pour moi qui est à mes yeux la plus
belle du cyclisme
de notoriété peut-être par rapport aux
cyclistes aussi
difficile de notoriété je vais juste
donner des noms sur la liste florian
rousseau tout le monde connaît florian
rousseau je pense ou alors
[Rires]
de promotion de publicité je pense que
c'est complètement et parce que parce
que ben voilà au début on se disait
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas de karting
c'est parce que ceux ci c'est parce que
cela met les eaux peuvent le faire donc
pourquoi est-ce que le pourquoi se
contenter du vélo on n'y arrive pas
alors que c'est le vélodrome nationale
moi je pense que c'est là qu'il faut
qu'il faut réfléchir il faut trouver les
solutions et l'époque et ras de terre
ouvrait le futur bon je voulais
judiciaires ou parce que c'est
parler aujourd'hui florian pervis faire
mon père vit c'est pareil c'est dans le
milieu du cyclisme se soit perdu j'ai
dit quoi gfr
mais françois pervis séparer on sait
aujourd'hui enfin tous les jeunes qui
font du vélo connaissent françois pervis
grégory baugé a porté très haut les
couleurs de la france pendant pendant
plusieurs années on a on a des donc la
notoriété du cyclisme non je suis désolé
on a on a toujours eu des champions du
monde on a en louis aptitudes et des
creux mais ça a été très très court
aujourd'hui sébastien vigier et puis ma
team de gros selon les deux prochains
qui vont qu'il faut voir courir et qu'il
faut faire courir
donc non pour moi voilà il ya un souci
il faut le prendre dans le bon sens pour
pour remplir ce vélodrome donc on va
refaire mais votre coup de gueule il ya
eu viol de cinq minutes alors en un mois
quand même le vélodrome a tiré deux des
plus gros événements en ile-de-france
ajoutez à cela des coupes d'hiver de
cyclisme sur piste yann jarrier un
record le grand gala du club du cyclisme
2 vélizy 78 également qui a réuni plus
de 1500 personnes au début du mois au
mois de mars il ya eu un match de d1
féminine entre issy paris et brest le
record de robert marchand en janvier
dernier sur la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 105 ans on a
beaucoup tapé sur le drone dans cette
émission mais là on a l'impression que
la tendance s'inverse la question sur ce
thème avez vous le sentiment que le
vélodrome national a franchi un palier
oui ou non à toute l'organisation qui
s'est faite sur ces derniers mois
non jean vous êtes encore indécis loyer
du
nombre on fait un petit duel entre vous
jean et yann à les gens vont commencer
j'ai mis l'ordre parce qu'il a mis oui
à bâle y est je suis pas y ait un palier
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'organisations
mais c'est le propre d'un mouvement
sportif celle utilisée de gros
événements quand même deux des plus
roses éléments d'accord mais alors
c'est la base d'un équipement sportif
celle utilisée donc s'il n'est pas
utilisé et il coûte des sous donc autant
d'utiliser et l'utiliser avec des sports
qui amène du monde ça irait à la boxe et
le judo et non pas c'est bien de dévier
cette
structure du sport initial pour lequel
il était prévu et qui visiblement
n'attire pas son monde ce qui est même
aussi vous avez oublié de citer il ya eu
aussi d'organiser la tartiflette géante
du club du 3e âge de montigny le
bretonneux qui a attiré 2700 personnes
donc en avant vos biens qu'ils allaient
qu'il ya des sports qui n'arrive
qu'il arrive à ce niveau là
à vous monsieur dujarrier
par contre je voulais quand même
féliciter du coup le directeur du
vélodrome pour le ninja rouge à rocky
qui fait un travail un très très gros
travail pourtant vous étiez pessimistes
en eau
il avait été nominé à l'époque oui parce
que l air
alors on avait on avait peur parce que
c'était de faire un mini bercy et donc
on avait peur pour nos activités
cyclisme globalement ça se passe pas
trop mal maintenant c'est la
multiplication des événements le
week-end ne font que les créneaux
cycliste disparaissent donc ça c'est moi
je m'entraîne beaucoup de week end en
vélo donc ça va falloir falloir que ça
s'arrête à un moment ou un autre non pas
se leurrer la boxe pour les
entraînements blague à part blague à
part c'est vrai que ils ont dépisté ils
veulent développer quand même l'activité
cyclisme est donc encore promouvoir avec
de très belles de très belles épreuves
type d un des six jours c'est vraiment
l'objectif du vélodrome c'est d'avoir
une épreuve de six jours sur sur le
vélodrome ce samedi l'épreuve de séjour
à très basse et plus et des réunions
pendant pendant six jours alors à
l'époque on sa tournée pendant six jours
ça ça ne s'arrêtait jamais maintenant
voilà c'est chaque soir mais donc avec
plein des avec plein d'épreuves des
épreuves d'endurance des épreuves de
sprint gélose séduire par le vent dans
le vélodrome donc il faut qu'ils aient
du vélodrome est un défi qu'ils veulent
ils voudraient aussi avoir des
révolutions series c'est une épreuve qui
est né en angleterre il ya quelques
années et donc peut-être pouvoir
délocaliser et le faire en france ça a
été
ça a été annulée l'année dernière mais
le projet reste reste quand même ils
sont toujours en contact et donc voilà
ils veulent ils veulent continuer de
promouvoir et de et d'organiser deux
belles épreuves et donc avec des belles
affiches et
le club de vélizy souhaite aussi
organiser quelque chose alors peut-être
l'année prochaine ou en 2019 un grand
prix
qui ne serait basé sur de la vitesse
l'autre avec un avec un très très beau
plateau de
2 deux champions de champions
internationaux voilà on a des idées
maintenant voilà il faut il faut que
tout le monde joue le jeu pour que pour
sa fille
hélène alesi hélène qui a qui a raison
qui a tort
c'est plutôt du côté de ses biens c'est
bien d'eux
c'est vraiment bien de mettre plusieurs
disciplines de remplir et de faire
connaître aussi le lieu je pense qu'à
vraiment un problème de
communication d'expliquer vraiment tout
moi j'aimais bien l'idée des six-jours
l'avait vraiment des épreuves
différentes tous les jeux faisant tous
les soirs et c est ce que ça a déjà été
c'est bien sûr il a
changé le dressage à mettet chose qu'il
faut beaucoup communiquer même au sein
des classes je ne viens pas déjà alors
sur six jours il ya eu le cas à l'époque
il y avait il y avait le grand prix
grand prix des nations à bercy et es9 et
bercy donc ces vingt mille personnes à
bercy c'était plein tous les soirs ça
durait trois quatre jours ou migrer hors
mais c'est elle a sauté du toit de
france qui
une trilogie si je devais penser à
organiser un loto
et pour le grand prix de vélizy va
également peut-être avoir des stars
internationales également qui pourrait
venir on va d on a des relais des
championnats des champions du monde
junior des champions du monde seniors
qui viennent tous les ans donc déjà on a
à chaque fois on a un très très haut
plateau ça pour attirer plus de monde on
arrive déjà pour un grand prix avec des
coureurs régionaux à avoir peu près 1000
personnes dans les gradins à chaque fois
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir faire une
une démonstration un jour devant devant
le vélodrome où il y avait 4000
personnes c'est un réel kif c'est
vraiment mais quelque chose de
j'avais jamais vécu ça ce jour là en
plus on courait avec avec quentin et
avec quentin lafargue et d'autres
d'autres athlètes de l'équipe de france
c'était c'était génial quoi et voilà moi
ce que je veux c'est pouvoir revivre ces
choses à vendre avant d'arrêter les 11
août d'ailleurs j'ai justement non mais
c'est ça tu vois d'aider des athlètes
vraiment de haut niveau bien communiquer
mettre des épreuves un peu particulière
voilà jean tulard sergent apprennent que
tous n'étaient pas des cdd des
prédateurs et voilà david de david
douillet non teddy riner ne pas qu'on
n'était pas là pour combattre maintenant
le voeu de route est plein et le
vélodrome était plaint parce que pour
des raisons économiques aussi les
billets d'accès étaient vendus dix
balles 10 euros alors que quand vous
faites une organisation vélodrome s'est
tout de suite 35,40 euros on vous
demande l'offre eagles c'est pas gratuit
il comprend les gens peuvent pas vous
des gens peuvent pas venir avec leurs
enfants c'est impossible et bien moi je
préfère voir un vélodrome plein avec
diddy
5000 personnes à 10 balles plutôt que
1000 personnes à 3030 balle quoi et là
je pense que la fédé et c'est là la
fédération la fédération se plante à
chaque fois donc pour revenir à la
question initiale est ce que le
vélodrome a franchi un palier sur vous
oui mais parce que je pense que c'est en
vélo mais sans le vélo parce que et il
faut pas rêver parce que les
organisations qui se sont faites
soit du judo de la boxe ou d'autres
sports c'est pas la fédération française
qui s'en occupe ces vélos police et
vélos police et la société qui gère le
fonctionnement du vélodrome donc c est
avec le soutien de la fédération de judo
ou avec d'une d'un promoteur de boxe
donc ils le font jamais tout seul mais
c'est bizarre dès que la fédération
française n'est pas né pas né pas l
affaire française de cyclisme n'est pas
acteur et ben ça fonctionne donc pour
moi ils lui disent facile de trouver le
coupable fredrik andersson est ce que le
vélodrome peut devenir l'une des plus
grandes enceintes sportives d'île de
france abat le problème sans voix la
dynamique qui vient s'enclencher depuis
à plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois ben
on voit qu'ils sont capables d'organiser
des gros événements le seul problème
comme disait yann c'est que ça s'appelle
un vélodrome est pas un palais
omnisports donc si vous voulez appeler
ça un vélodrome pour vous faut mettre du
vélo il faut attirer des gens pour le
vélo si on appelle ça un palais
omnisports est par contre après ça le
met directement en concurrence avec
paris bercy
et la problématique du vélodrome quand
même pour certains sports et je suis je
suis toujours fait je suis étonné parce
que c'est que quand on veut un talent
jouer les spectateurs personne n'en
parle mais je pense que sur certains
événements les gens sont peut-être un
petit peu loin d'eux
un match de boxe apparemment pour le
judo comme on l'entendait
juillet apparemment il est au contraire
elle était ravie de l'emplacement j'ai
vu la la la construction et la nouvelle
configuration les voir à plusieurs
combats en même temps voilà il y avait
il y avait six ou sept tatami ça c'est
ça se fait jamais ça se fait jamais
mutuellement plutôt moyenne à 2 ou 3 23
je crois de quelques soient les salles
de classe est vrai que tous de voir
beaucoup mais voilà 1 2 3 6 7 ses
facettes donc c'était c'était vraiment
très très sympa et donc du coup vous en
aviez automatiquement inquiéter minimum
devant vous même si d'autres pouvaient
être pouvait être plus éloigné mais et
est donc par pour la boxe c'est vrai que
bon c'est quand même un rôle qui est
centrale je pense que les gens qui sont
dans l'est dans les gradins du vélodrome
peuvent eux peuvent être un petit peu
loin il aurait fallu enlever mais être
la piste du vélodrome l'a pensé
autrement peut-être à la conception est
ce qu'il n'aura pas pu y avoir des
gradins amovibles qui soit qu'ils soient
installés mais bon alors là à chaque
fois ça voulait dire que quinze jours
avant on fermait le vélodrome et l'accès
aux abonnés quoi et là là je serai
encore moins content
si je fais comme ça du cyclisme on va en
parler dans notre focus du jour
dans notre focus du jour nous allons
parler donc de cyclisme a triste
nouvelle pour le cyclisme tricolore
c'était à craindre l'équipe de l'armée
de terre ne sera plus dans le peloton
l'année prochaine l'équipe continental
3e division professionnelle va
disparaître dès l'année prochaine sur
décision du ministère désormais équipe
avec ray été créés en 2011 et avait
notamment révélé de jeunes talents
tricolores comme julian alaphilippe où
les viennois morgan kneisky où on en art
alors on en a parlé de gâchis pourquoi
gâchis parce que c'est du gâchis
attendez je vais continuer je l'est
continueront leur revient juste à me
faire alors on en a parlé on a parlé de
budget pour justifier cette décision
l'équipe coûté un peu plus de 1,5
million d'euros par an mais visiblement
l'armée pourrait payer les quoi encore
sous contrat pendant trois ans le
problème c'est que le recrutement a
évidemment voilà c cloud vm évidemment
clôturer la décision était trop tardive
est ce que la décision a été trop
tardive selon vous oui ou non on parlera
de gâcher juste après alors oui ou non
décision trop tardive n'a pas dit
qu'elle était trop tardif donc je
maigris route vous allez vous avait
coûté la vie
pourquoi yann pour les couvreurs tout
simplement voilà le mercato
le mercato dans le cyclisme il se
commence la sortie du tour de france
c'est le 31e 31 juillet vous faites une
annonce le 15 novembre voilà tout le
monde a fini son tour n'a fini son
recrutement donc en effet là il va y
avoir une quinzaine de coureurs qui se
retrouvent sur le sur le carreau donc
attendre quinzaine excusez moi
donc voilà donc quinze coureurs et en
plus avec des avec des avec de vrais
talents
comme morgan comme morgan kneisky et
puis et puis des jeunes qui avait été
recruté trois fois champion du monde sur
l'américaine mais ce qui est bien sûr et
avec des jeunes qui avaient été recrutés
il il ya très peu de temps pour en se
disant ben voilà on le l'objet de
l'objectif et le projet c'est d'être sur
le tour de sur les routes du tour de
france en 2021 donc donc voilà il y
avait il y avait quelque chose qui était
et est prévu pour dans la continuité et
donc voilà pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
un réel gâchis
et encore une fois c'est parce que des
gens qui sont derrière un bureau bain
pour économiser un milliard 1 million et
400000 euros alors que l'image qu'ils
étaient dégagés par cette équipe était
était vraiment très très bonne dans le
milieu du dos le milieu du vélo ils ont
vraiment gravi gravi des échelons et à
partir du moment où ils ont dominé dans
le niveau amateur ils ont essayé très
rapidement de de passer au niveau
professionnel malgré la difficulté parce
qu'il y avait des histoires de statut
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué à ce moment là ils n'ont pas
hésité à aller
aller au charbon pour pouvoir finalement
réussir à courir dans les rangs
professionnels ils ont des résultats en
plus c'est pas la plus grosse structure
s'est passé pas le plus gros budget chez
les hommes chez lui et chez les pros
mais voilà il arrivait à grandir à
grossir petit à petit et je trouve ça je
trouve vraiment ça dommage parce qu'en
plus ils étaient accompagnés par
d'autres partenaires qui vont aussi du
coup se retrouver se retrouver sur le
carreau peut-être pouvoir les récupérer
pour le team master
mais met donc voilà maintenant cesser
c'est dommage parce que parce que
c'était une belle c'était une belle
aventure et
et ça fait des années qu'on est complice
lui qu'on les regarde
moi je suis je suis je suis vraiment je
suis vraiment parce que ben ouais je
suis déçu parce que parce que c'est un
million quatre cent mille euros pour moi
je pense que dans le budget du ministère
de la défense c'est une goutte d'eau
donc donc dommage et vont continuer à
payer ils vont continuer à payer les
salles et les églises ils sont contre à
vingt trois ans enfin l'autre
certainement pas parce que les gars et
scrabble arcil par apple ça va rouvrir
ce qu'ils veulent c'est courir et
morgane il a besoin d'avoir une
structure pour pouvoir aller courir sur
route donc même si on perd à participer
aux jeux olympiques de tokyo et voilà
énorme et morgane il veut pas participer
aux jeux olympiques de tokyo ces centres
collectifs n'ont gagné qu'à participer
ça n'intéresse pas donc donc voilà et
donc pour pouvoir gagner il faut pouvoir
aller se frotter au plus haut niveau on
sait bien que ben voilà les gelées des
champions olympiques en titre c'est
on
n'a qu'à les petits mark cavendish et
son collègue anglais voilà ça convient
pas mais c'est pas grave voilà ces deux
anglais qui court chez les
professionnels donc belle lui il a pas
le choix faut pouvoir aller se
s'affronter enfin se confronter au plus
haut niveau sur la route pour être bon
en américaine fred anderson vous n'étiez
pas du même avis que yann cochin je
trouve pas que c'est enfin
particulièrement tard par rapport aux
coureurs bien sûr parce que c'est au
niveau le calendrier sportif s'est
creusé ces terres catholiques l'eau on
peut le dire après ça c'est pas je suis
pas plus surpris que ça je veux dire
élections présidentielles nouveau
gouvernement nouvelles priorités qui
sont qui sont affichées le nouveau
gouvernement a pas assuré et forcément
les choix du gouvernement précédent et
ce avec un poignant bien sûr en 2011 sa
saison que c'était le président cité le
gouvernement précédent qui avait tout
mis en place et ils sont d'où on a autre
chose à faire surtout que bon au final
c'est quand même le ministère de la
défense est pas le ministère des sports
et je pense que quelque part on peut
comprendre que c'est plus la mission
parce que pendant longtemps ça l'a été
le ministère de la défense avait des
équipes militaires de soldats qu'ils
envoyaient sur des championnats mondiaux
et sait où on était performant mais le
paysage sportif à évoluer le sport a
pris une
position prépondérante et je pense que
le ministère des sports est plus à même
de gérer ce genre de
ce genre d'organisation que la défense
qui elle a pour but pas de défendre le
pays plutôt que l'organisation d'organes
l'organiser des équipes de niamey locaux
alors là
si j'ai parlé un sport mineur qui y
attenant et s'il n'y avait pas les
douanes et l'armée on ne serait jamais
la plus grande nation
et d'un sport ni d'orgue d'un sport d'un
sport quand même d'un sport mineur en
france c'est pas un sport le big
étranglée par un sport mineur en
allemagne n'est pas un sport mineur en
norvège n'est pas un sport mineur dans
les pays dans les pays nordiques et
c'est un sport qui qui qui rayonne
énormément et est aujourd'hui ben nos
athlètes des athlètes français sont tous
des athlètes qui sont ralliés à la soie
aux toiles soit
non non non non non ils sont annoncés
d'armé qui cesser d'armer ou à la cdac
la police qu'il est et qui les
rémunèrent qui sont payés deux arrêts
tout à fait martin martin fourcade est
caporal je crois caporal-chef de mémoire
vérifier même genre qui a raison qui a
tort
je pense frédéric un réseau
qui simple va tous ces blancs parce
qu'il a tout à fait raison dans la
mesure où moi je connais le phénomène
donc il a tout à fait raison ces
politiques parce que justement les blés
les principaux intérêts des différents
ministères ne sont personne de même
les les intérêts des principaux
ministères cacité même il ya ce soit la
police l'armée ou les où les doigts la
politique la politique change la
politique a changé énormément et ce
n'est plus du tout une priorité et on va
dire que c'est dans le contexte actuel
il est mal venu de mettre en avant et de
mettre de l'argent sur des gens qui font
du sport même si nous avec notre regard
sportif on dit mais il représente
quelque chose mais c'était un regard
sportif vous avez de l'autre côté des
regards administrative qui vous disent
non moi ça me coûte un million de 4 donc
un million quatre mois j'ai autre chose
à faire avec un million quatre que de
faire faire du sport à des gens voilà ce
que vous répondrez c'est une et c'est
uniquement la raison politique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on voit la disparition de
cette équipe c'est qu'on transpose pas
la question
voilà on voit on voit juin à la philippe
qui a participé au tour de france
notamment qui est sorti de là on peut se
dire également que c'est une aide au
ministère des sports par exemple alors
c'est une adversaire du sport mais est
encore une fois de plus ceux d'éric
lavigne pourquoi le ministère des sports
ne ne reprend pas à son compte tous ces
sportifs là parce que finalement c'est
ni plus ni moins et se décharger sur les
autres ministères puisque c'est eux qui
payent parce que les gens appartiennent
à telle corporation que ce soit des
douaniers des policiers ou des
militaires et donc ça permet au
ministère des sports de simplement
donner une subvention pour dire vous
avez des sportifs de haut niveau dans
notre corporation donc on vous donne une
petite subvention mais au lieu de payer
un million de cartes a par exemple ils
doivent peut-être donner 4,5 me dois
surtout qu'ils le font déjà c'est par
exemple les sportifs de haut niveau sont
employés à temps partiel à la pause tout
à l'atp sur des sur d'autres sur
d'autres fonctions publiques donc ils
sont capables de le faire je pense que
la meilleure chose à faire c'est pour le
ministère des sports de récupérer cette
mission là qui est exactement dans bad
ans dans ses missions il faut savoir que
par exemple les âmes congrès que j'ai
très rapidement c'est au niveau de la
police au niveau de la police il
existait des sportifs de haut niveau des
sportifs valeurs nationales ce qu'on
appelait avec des avantages au niveau
administratif et avec des budgets donné
par l'administration par le ministère de
l'intérieur ces avantages se sont
arrêtés en janvier 2010 c'est à dire que
la politique fait que sait il n'ya plus
de sportifs de haut niveau rattachés à
la police il ya que des contrats
imagined voilà donc c'est juste pour
schématiser très rapidement en tout cas
rien à cacher le faire rapidement en
tout cas s'il y en a un qui a bien senti
le coup ces hébergements à thomas qui
est parti à la fdj pour deux saisons
juste avant l'annoncé
rihanna commentaires là dessus il avait
senti le coup boutique wii petit coup je
suis en effet ce que ce que ce que oui
bah oui parce que j'avais bien que le
contracter ça ressemble à ce que disait
frédéric voilà en effet changement de
gouvernement il y avait des
alerte qui pouvait être être émises ben
oui benjamins i là il a bien joué après
il a il a eu la proposition aussi des
délices et pas c'est pas non plus et
puis s'il est la proposition c'est qu'il
l'a mérité
maintenant je pense que morgane mérite
aussi d'avoir une place dans un groupe
sportif vers de l'amérique dans un
groupe sportif professionnel pour
pouvoir voilà simplement allez allez
rayonner sur la piste et puis même sûr
et même sur la route parce que il sera
il sera aussi très difficile
voilà on va clôturer cette page cyclisme
jan vous pouvez un petit peu sous de
l'aide on va passer maintenant notre
rubrique débats
nous allons prendre le large dans cette
rubrique débats la 13ème édition de la
transat jacques vabre s'est terminée mi
novembre les deux bateaux événements
terminés à la course le versailles et à
tanguy de lamotte et sa coéquipière
samantha davies trop de vélo au vélo
genlis voilà on passe à la voile en je
sais pas si ça vous serez plus inspiré
alors en tout cas le versailles et
tanguy la mode sa coéquipière samantha
davies ont terminé à la sixième place du
classement en imoca en 15 jours 3 heures
59 minutes et 46 secondes ils ont
devancé le bar le bateau au bureau
vallée durant vos little louis burton
qui a pris la 7e place de la course avec
sa femme servane escoffier à quelques
heures de tanguy de lamotte une petite
déception pour ce dernier qui espérait
accrocher le podium avec son nouveau
bateau équipé de foils mais il s'est
fait piéger dans par le vent au milieu
de la course mais pour louis burton
l'expérience reste positive en est
une machine qui est très exigeant que
le cac perd très vite pour un monocoque
de cette taille là c'est un comportement
assez violent un peu de la survie à bord
ça t'a beaucoup dans les vagues afin
d'accélérer fort ça freine quand forme
directe après donc il ya deux ans tout
un apprentissage de pas tellement des
madoff mais en tout cas de la vie à bord
d'un bateau à foix est comme ça et ça
permet de temps aussi la mesure de ce
qui doit supporter pendant le tour du
monde qui était le nom de trois ans qui
va durer votre souris 80 jours
on avait donc deux optiques sur cette
course pour nos deux yvelinois louis
burton qui vous lie grimper sur le
podium avec son nouveau bateau à l'imoca
équipés de foils ds sous le bateau qui
permettent de voler on peut le dire sur
l'eau de son côté tanguy de lamotte
voulait terminer sa carrière en beauté
et surtout sauver 13 enfants grâce à son
association initiative coeur finalement
il en a sauvé à 25 la question sur ce
thème les deux illinois ont ils réussi
leur course par rapport à leurs
objectifs
vous êtes contre tout le monde il ya
seul contre tous offert un petit duel
entre vous et les ja c'est parti ça va
vite fait mais
au final y avait deux objectifs il en a
fait un des deux c'est sûr qu'après y
avait son objectif sportif de bain de
faire un dernier podium voilà ça n'a pas
été le cas il a eu des
ouïes assayas a mais des personnes
abonnées la démence et mobil a abandonné
au bout de deux semaines oui pour un
problème de mât pourtant il ameute un
bien sûr je précise
mais non il ya quand même un des deux
objectifs de
de
réaliser maintenant c'est sûr que ça se
termine pas aussi enfin sportivement
aussi haut que ce qu'il aurait voulu
pour une dernière comptant pourtant
bilan mitigé on va dire positif au
niveau au niveau des enfants parlent
pour lui porter pour vous c'est
l'objectif est rempli ou pas quand on
voit que louis burton a terminé 7e de la
course alors qu'il visait le top 3
avec un nouveau bateau bon après nouveau
bateau pas d'expérience il a pas sauvé
l'enfant c'est pas la marque de
vêtements
justice a
peut-être
être que en temps quand on veut chercher
le podium et contaminent 6e ou 7e on
on n'a pas atteint son objectif
maintenant c'est pas non plus négatif
puisque on apprend aussi dans la dans la
défaite j'ai déjà dis donc et c'est ce
qui c'est ce qu'il disait il c'est un
nouveau bateau c'est une première
expérience avec ce bateau il a ils ont
ils ont pris ils ont pris contact avec
ceux avec ce bateau ils ont appris ils
ont appris pendant sept pendant cette
traversée ben en foulard souhaité que
pour la suite ça ça se passe bien et ça
se passe mieux et alain dru dans
l'interview son objectif c'est le vendée
globe ce n'était pas forcément la
transat jacques vabre même s'il espérait
tout de même faire un brin de classe
avec un bateau qui utilise celui d'armel
le cléac'h j'ai remporté le dernier
vendée globe
pourquoi
nous formule 1 tu es tu mets au volant
d'une formule 1 ben je serai dernier sur
la grille comme comme 95% des trains 19%
mais
maintenant maintenant voilà oui c'est
pas c'est pas toujours matériel qui le
fait et c'est ce qu'on avait c'est ce
qu'on avait dit puisque en effet les sur
le vendée globe le foeil le leur avait
permis de
avait permis au premier de battre les
anciens records mais les suivantes
n'allait pas tous tous battu le record
malgré des foils aussi sur sur les sur
les bateaux donc donc voilà c'est tout
ça a permis moins d'abandons en tout cas
sur ce sur cette transat jacques vabre
il ya 100% des imoca qui sont arrivés
bâton avant les précédentes où il y
avait du 80 90 % ce bon donc c'est quand
même une c'est comme une traversée où il
ya quand même peu de peu de peu
d'abandons en général on voit là c'est
ils ont eu des conditions qui étaient
peut-être un peu un peu optimum le
matériel aussi qui s'améliore
certainement
d'expérience en expérience même si la
voix la voile c'est pas c'est pas un
sport récent ce n'est pas un saut s'est
passé pince portneuf maintenant voilà
wee cc des beaux bateaux c'est c'est
quelque chose qui
dont on parle de plus en plus et qui
mérite parce que ce sont ce sont quand
même de 2,2 de vrais sportifs accomplis
aussi parce que
il faut il faut il faut les piloter
c'est ces monstres 1 parce que là quand
on les voit au milieu de l'océan ça
ressemble à rien mais quand on va les
voir quand on va les voir dans l'est
dans les ports voilà c'est vraiment
impressionnant la taille de la taille de
ces bateaux il faut il faut avoir les
cojones bien bien à sa place pour pour y
aller et s'y mettre à deux pour pour le
pour le piloter et l'emmener landes et
pendant une quinzaine de jours voilà
gens vous qui n'êtes plus un spécialiste
de pédalos on peut le dire un peu
voilent est ce que vous êtes satisfait
de la course
louis burton là c'est un guy lamothe
magnac et pourquoi de la noyade
problèmes cardiaques problème cardiaque
cardiac 25 à la fois
jouer au loto c'est parti avec sa femme
non c'est louis burton qui est parti
avec sa hache et analyse les doigts
je tous les deux et leurs tonnes est
parti avec sa femme il vient de
rambouillet et viendra mouillée est en
vie la mode vient de versailles et il a
sauvé 25 enfants mais paris par son
opération rachat reka et cette grâce à
l'opération mais je trouve ça très bien
très bien c'est fantastique il à sauver
des âmes enfin on ne peut dire bravo
merci merci messieurs burton peut-être
qu'il y ait débat parti et sa femme
fehmida on ne saura jamais
rapidement fait d'accord personne n'a
pas parlé sur la question
y at il
une association qui est très importante
ces décès des enfants qui sont cons des
prêts m cadettes dans des pays
défavorisés qui nous qui ne sont pas
équipés qui sont là prêts à accueillir
en france et qui sont soignés par des
chirurgiens en france et donc l'objectif
de cette association c'est de trouver
des familles d'accueil pour pour le mois
où les peut-être chaussée puis c'est un
mois deux mois ou trois mois le temps
d'hospitalisation pour pouvoir soigner
ses enfants donc en effet c'est très
très important et cette association a un
un vrai but il a par avril sur le bateau
non il nous apparaît sur le bateau voilà
donc il faut il faut en parler il faut
en parler a été intelligemment j'aime
beaucoup cette association très
rapidement vous avez de 30 secondes pour
louis burton fredrik andersson bas ils
voulaient faire top 3 il a fait top 7
c'est raté
[Rires]
ça sera le mot de la fin c'est donc la
fin de cette émission se retrouvent le
jeudi à 14 décembre pour la dernière
émission de l'année et oui déjà et on va
terminer par une citation d'un célèbre
footballeur le king eric cantona je ne
joue pas contre une équipe en
particulier je joue pour me battre
contre l'idée de perdre je vous laisse à
bientôt sur tv soit 118
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]